>>> ONE OF THE FANCIES H THEE AA
DELICIOUSTAURANTS IN STUNNINNOUE
PHAM FRE
IT IS PART OF A
THATEEMSLOWLY
GATHERING MO AND MORM.LE ARE SEA
WORKING MY WAY TO HAVI MS MEAT.E
IMSAR MEATLEEA  YOU.
>> SO TELLOUT YOURY, BECAUSE YOU
EATER.GHTEOU
YOU POST PICS S
WHAT HAPD?OUADNOWAY WE TREN ORYS
MY MIND AND THS WHAT NYVEUT THAS
R ORTH AND THEN FOR A
YOU LET MYSELFAVE
IKODT RGT BES ANTH SHOULD HAPPE
OUS. DOING TO THT E ALS ANOU AN
>> SO LET' ABOUT THI
BILLIOANTEEA DWE KNOD THE CLIMAT
EFHAT IS J
ANIMALS, BUT 80 BILLION LAND IM.
O RAIS
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE THE NOLO
ANIMALS THAT ARE BRED TO GRO
REALLYWEUMUL ANTIBIOTICSHE OTIDE
, THAT IS FINE.
THAT IS NOT SOMETHIN C ABOUT. OL
ENONQUS
BEUSS MUTATEEVOLVEN ESE PACKED T
S ANANBIES
SO T IT OF ANIMAL SUFFERBU T OO.
HAB
T OF THAT  USED
D NE STEP HE MATTERS
IS WHAT IS OFTEN HE IS YOUR CLEN
AND THEY KEEP IT IN THE GROUND
PUIN
HAPPENG  AMAZOAN COWR DIFFERENT
THE TAKING PAR
D
T ISIT WITH AN UNNAT ONE THAT SN
MELTS THEAN
COULD I NALLY ABOUT ATAY
IF YOU DO TH T H
D DO THAT WOULD MATTER THESTOU .
AND I WAY EABECAUSE PEOPLE DID
RECOENDING TYBODY. WOULD BE PRO.
ITS E
LESS
THE SINGE
AT FROM THEI DO THE HAT IS WORS
ILL EACO ARNDIS WORSE THAWSO
E DIET EDING SO MANANINVOLVED.
>> YD OUCOLUMN THAT YOU WROTAB
THIS, AMERANESS HA
FEF
H SUBSTITUTES
A LOT LIKE MEUT E PLANT BASED?
>> YEAH, THIS IS A REMBL
GE ITH YEARS.
VE TOEN YOU
HABLE FOODS AND BEYOND
MEAT AES
BACHT TASTE ELL
D.
WORTH IMSS WHO.U  TAS USER THE G
DIFFERENCE.
YOU COULT
FIAN BN TERMS MAL FOODWORKS WELY
THST THAT IS THE KEY
INY  B AMERICA IFE ACCELERATE TA
WE OURNOMIC VALUE
IPCONGCO THE NEXT
COUPLE OE PUNDAB